we open as we usually do with the
southern narrator talking over flat
landscapes probably shot by Raja
Deaconess they leave just enough space
for the credits to go over but they
rarely take advantage of that in-state
believe me to tell you about a main
character a fat cat that's right a
political fat cat trying to shift things
his way by simply throwing money at his
problems this is usually where we cut to
a symbol of the movie while a Carter
Burwell score plays
[Music]
and even if he was a lace man quite
possibly the laziest in Muncie Indiana
he will push him pretty far by staring
at his calendar so he would know when
mondays were coming honestly we hold all
these awkward stairs to a point where it
becomes gimmicky but the critics seem to
like it
but even fat cats have owners like Jon
Arbuckle here played by Steve Buscemi
you got a job to do man I give you money
so that you can spend it on keeping
those rats pie out of our political
house I told you boogies on it take the
rats out of the house Garfield he's just
angry because he can't get a date from
one of his party supporters an army
veteran named Burrell is played by
Frances McDorman so uh lass how about
that date you're not just asking me
because I'm a vet are you there are
rules hoping that the comedic lead s
praying Oliver rolls the creepy stalker
angles sorry John I have to draw a line
in the sand and apart from millions of
fans demanding that I break character
and date you know that really happened
look it up I'm going to keep this
running joke running damn running joke
Garfield had many people he couldn't
stand like nermal the wise black man who
was so humble and sage like that it made
him despicably cute he's played by some
salt-of-the-earth actor that can easily
be switched out the next time they do
this cliche
yeah he'll do suppose we should probably
do that simple plan during with a
complicated best thing those let me see
if I'll kill her you know your best
friend's been taking half the shipment
right what thought it was off the stuff
come on boy
falling off countertops walking on all
fours
you can barely speak half the time you
know nermal I think it's time I sent you
to Abu Dhabi in a box
[Music]
that's right you don't know whether or
not to vote for me and finally there's
Odie played by John Tudor oh I'm a dog
I'm a dog woof woof bark bark my skin's
turning yellow sorry it's come to this
Odie Garfield is that you but the time
has come to put you down go to I'm gonna
kill you in a gruesome yeah quirky way
they won't know what they actually like
the movie after seeing it but after they
let it sit for a while they'll figure to
themselves yeah that's fucked up enough
I guess I like it fine that's lunch
everybody
Cowen's I just want to say again I am so
thankful that you're having me star in
your latest movie I mean where did you
get the idea to have me play an
egotistical lazy jerk god I see where
you guys get your gift for dialogue
anyway I just want to say thank you so
much again I know you didn't just cast
me in this role because I have a studio
and I'm letting you use it for free we
don't really care that clearly shows me
directed Ladykillers hey joel great work
on the shoot today sweetie
I'm Joel oh I'm sorry I always get you
two mixed up
we don't care oh hey critic what's your
next scene well I actually I don't know
I guess the Cohens have to Tim oh I hate
it when they do that yeah okay I'm just
gonna go do a review about always Tyson
to my personal life somehow good work
everybody
good work timing is everything
who would have thought the Coen brothers
would actually make a Garfield movie I
mean this newspaper comic strip that was
also Saturday morning cartoon and the
directors of gritty surreal suspense
they just go hand in hand
too bad Bill Murray didn't know that
Wayne signed on to do the first one not
that Bill Murray is a bad choice to play
Garfield in fact it's actually fitting
seeing how the late voice actor Lorenzo
music for police Maria's Peter in the
real
Buster's and now Murray is replacing
music as Garfield however that wasn't
the reason he didn't he agreed to it
because he thought the writer joel coen
was up the critically-acclaimed Coen
Brothers when really he was from the
critically panned Cheaper by the Dozen
because of this Murray didn't read the
entire script and blindly agreed to take
the role bit of a mistake there what
followed was a painfully painful bit of
pain that's so bad that even Murray's
talent couldn't save it
fans of anything Garfield could quickly
see not only did this have little to do
with what made the character so
entertaining but it was going to punish
you for liking those things to begin
with it's a hard one to watch whether
you're a fan of the beloved cartoon or
not there's a lot of kitty litter to get
through so let's start scooping this is
Garfield that's the credits roll we see
pictures of a man who clearly likes his
pet too much who wears a suit in a
picture with your Catalan or Bond
villain when we get our first glimpse of
our main character oh my god is that
hideous and that only is he simply ugly
but the CG is so bad that I actually
think the hand-drawn commercials from
the past look more convincing he looks
like grumpy cat if she was shit out by
chester Cheetah just to give you an idea
these are the hard drives of jokes I
made based on his appearance but seeing
outside short review let's just stick to
the best of the best the Sunkist tumor
seems to do things associated with
Garfield geese lasagne annoys his owner
John played by brick and mayor who we
pray to God will make fun of this a
Robot Chicken thank you and talks with
annoying friends like nermal just seems
like a weird fuck is that doggie to a
house that already has a cat ah maybe
you heard me wrong hangs out with nermal
come on it's just across the street
where catch we like a milk atta boy
nermal yeah you're really going with
that huh that that this is nerville last
time I checked normal was said to be the
world's cutest kitty cat he was innocent
had a sweet high-pitched voice and
Garfield resented how adorable he was
here
well you've got that he's a cat on the
back of a DVD barks it makes even less
sense because Garfield doesn't have any
reason to hate him he's not cute he's
not a kitten he doesn't really even do
anything that annoying yet garfield
still puts him through this incredibly
implausible mousetrap stunt wow you were
really proud of that one weren't you I
mean it wasn't like a side joke or
something you said under your breath no
no you make sure everything went quiet
to deliver that incredible zinger got
milk got any idea what the fuck they
were thinking when they made this got
off sorry I'm sorry I know I'm only five
minutes in but I can just tell pain is
guaranteed on this viewing it actually
says it on the ticket stub as required
by the FCC so the font of fungus also
spends his time socializing with a mouse
named Lois Lois what are you doing in
the house
as long as you understand I have to hate
you you know this conversation is so
believable I mean between The Annoying
Orange triple I know isn't there and the
mouse that's clearly being tortured by
someone waving cheese above him I'm
really enjoying how these two fake
effects are not distracting from the
moment at all he also enjoys as you
probably observed making really forced
jokes that cats toast is everywhere TV
newspapers t-shirts wouldn't want that
kind of exposure well if it leads to a
cinematic testicle chop like this I
suppose know what let's go for a ride to
some place you love that always leaves
you feeling pampered and refresh chucky
cheese Wendy's
Taco Kitty Olive Garden for you
what about product placement are we
going to product placement I heard they
have really good buy this shit he takes
the pumpkin cancer to a vet named Liz
played by jennifer Love Hewitt some part
of me is always wanted to know what it'd
be like to have a pet that actually
wants to play with you you're a good
friend and you probably noticed the main
problem with her as it's the exact same
problem with John they're both too
good-looking and bland don't get me
wrong both these two have done good
stuff in other films but who is John
he's a doofus he's a dork he's the loser
that always strikes out who is Liz she's
a cynic she's a smart mouth she doesn't
care to impress anyone especially him
here they're a fucking greeting card
commercial they're not funny they're not
smart they're not quirky and their
chemistry is about as convincing as this
nurse holding a wad of lifeless air oh
sorry
Garfield but Luz decides to give John a
dog kinda random
his name's Odie and he's not gonna make
it if he has to live his life in a cage
he needs to be loved okay okay a couple
of things one there's gotta be a ton of
dogs around there that don't have homes
what makes this one so special I mean
what the hell if Garfield can look like
a computer-generated abortion why cant o
d look more like the cartoon for fuck's
sake at least make him like a beagle or
a basset hound I mean what the piss is
this are you trying to go for the Goomba
award and making something that looks
like something that looked like
something how come the majority of the
characters look nothing like the ones
they were based on if they like totally
changing characters around here right
Santa Christ yeah whatever bitch oh fuck
you ho I got a rocket ship and a Harley
wow he sure is acting strange isn't he
devil boner oh yeah totally strange
devil boomer I'm definitely devil boner
you wouldn't call me devil boner if I
wasn't double boner right well I guess I
can't ball you on that logic what do you
think
no using exactly the same that
son-of-a-bitch I knew I kept that gun
for the Ponyo review for a good reason
time for a sudden crossover so they take
Odie home to John's Hollywood rich house
paid by no seeable occupation we Rodian
the Lorax is blood don't seem to get
along you can tell of course because
they have a dance-off is that we step
out of here what I hope you're blown
away by this votes because it takes up a
good couple of minutes you probably
should have practiced in the garage
before you stepped up to someone of my
level huh yeah have you ever wanted to
entertain your baby while punishing him
at the same time just show Cupid's
nutsack dancing here and it'll give him
nightmares for a week I say this before
but you could be watching actual cat
videos and probably get a lot more out
of it so channel is take Odie to a dog
show that she has to judge how are they
gonna transmit them or something
no just brought them so he could watch
bizarrely useless but charm Andrews
pubic hair follows and naturally gets in
trouble I'll catch up with you it's
probably just a mild concussion Irv
maybe I'll get a cat scan a cat scan
quick vote um do you think the writer
weren't hours on that joke like stayed
up super late at night coffee after
coffee trying to perfect that joke or do
you feel like he ate sandpaper drank
some ink and farted out a screenplay
I am watched by good people the dogs
chase Wilford Brimley's urine-stained
moustache while Odie gets up and starts
to do this
[Music]
yes it is kind of amazing I mean can
science explain this a dog on his hind
legs but it just never happens I mean
fuck the butt ugly cat I can do karate
moves dance and we beyond any realm of
reality this dog is not as high right
[Applause]
okay it deserves a standing ovation why
don't we just blind to the miracle the
front page of the newspaper naturally
this is big news people
a dog stood on his hind legs could see
what else to applaud Oh what my
fingernails
[Applause]
I think we found our real headline town
high as hell now it's starting to see
why Garfield eat so much
[Applause]
you
so Tony the Tigers taint accidentally
max over the world's most accident-prone
room leading to Jon putting him outside
wait he puts the cat outside what's
really fucking dangerous
you know me I'm too lazy to try to
destroy your house yeah I'm too lazy to
destroy your house but not have several
dance sequences you can't kick me out of
my own house like I'm some kind of
animal
thanks for the leg of collar by the way
in case I get lost you're a seriously
terrible honor starfox ass hair lots OD
outside causing him to run away this
leads to him being found by a greedy TV
show host looking to bank on his
popularity as you can see Jonel is are
really torn up about it
we can't go out tonight why not Odie's
run away that almost made me change my
facial expression if I cared I'd be
really upset I can't find him why didn't
you just tell me I guess I figured it
was the only reason you were spending
time with me Wow I really believe they
were asked to say those lines so they go
looking for odie but the wet Loompa
Loompa armpit season on TV I take this
time to say that the product placement
in this film is not only bad its Man of
Steel bad
it's fucking everywhere not only is it
in every scene in the movie good but
it's in areas you wouldn't even see in
real life oh fuck puts Pepsi and Wendy
stickers on their train set or
depressingly say to their marketing team
you know what market we haven't tapped
yet trainsets I mean I was gonna invest
in this anime cat movie but the more I
think about it we got go where the real
gold is tiny little signs in this
incredibly popular demographic I think
you have something there Thank You Wendy
so takers : decides he's gonna try and
find Odie himself
no yep he's barely out the house he's
barely out the house he's barely out the
house he's barely out but let me just
look at him yeah he's barely out the
house if we guess the jokes before they
happen can we make the movie go faster
he gets the help of his friend Luis
who's now in the city
you know those commuting suburbia to big
city rats as he points out where Odie is
being held guess we'll just purge the
system don't you love those vents that
just take one button to purge the system
don't question the purge it just works
I'm just gonna choose to ignore this I
don't need anyone to know I was in a
Garfield movie he finds Odie only to
discover the owner is using an illegal
collar to control him and also works for
the President of the United States um
how does that work we have to make a
deal with Iran to get more electric
collars now some of you might see this
as a controversial but Bo needs to stop
wetting the bed Jake face works up
Odie's taken away but Starfire's moldy
couch isn't ready to give up
[Music]
dad let's have a moment of silence from
the audience oh wait you're watching
Garfield there's been nothing but
moments of silence from the audience my
life has been saved by the miracle of
lasagna it's a too late to be a Garfield
- Garfield movie well of course survives
but gets captured by a dog catcher and
put in the pound yeah that's right I
carry that nothing it's Oh looks like
you're trying to pretend that something
is there don't worry these animators
will get great jobs in Jurassic world
but the Heathcliff Mahmud freeze
everybody allowing him a distraction to
escape thus he goes to save Odie at the
train station where he's being taken
away what will you be having today
salmon steak or lasagna steak I hate
lasagna Oh see now we know he's the bad
guy not kidnapping the dog did put him
through a bunch of tortures no it's the
fact that he doesn't love lasagna and in
case you're wondering no this never
comes into play again
you think Garfield would not kabocha
lasagna or something but no it's an
entirely pointless lie it's like
shredder in the Ninja Turtles movie
suddenly saying or repeat saw just hold
out what you know that will you act like
a jerk sometimes to stop the train he
sneaks into the control panel and starts
randomly pushing buttons controlling
every single train because yeah that's
how it works
[Music]
I think I recognize that wine it's
similar to the people who want their
money back
good to see a partner the villain comes
in and stops them because clearly
neither of them could jump over that
suitcase yeah let's see just to recap
easy impossible to get over this movie
has a masters and what the fuckery and
let's see how you feel with 200 volts
coursing through that thick canine skull
of yours
I can't possibly find another dog who
stands on his hind legs
you're like the Jesus of canines but the
animals he free from the pound show up
to save the day
[Music]
Thanks okay they don't kill him but they
do put a stop to his evil plan just as
John and Liz show up to pretty much
contribute nothing so basically like the
rest of the film Garfield come here you
sack of air you so much and because this
movie had so many good idea that they
couldn't film the thematic running time
here's some completely pointless dancing
[Music]
yeah it literally ties into nothing it
just cuts to him dancing out of nowhere
[Music]
brought to you by a director who
actively hates his audience and that was
Garfield the movie how does it hold up I
think Bill Murray said it best do you
have any regrets
Garfield maybe Garfield is a great
character in many respects he's kind of
immortal much like the Looney Tunes or
Mickey Mouse even when he's not funny
we'll still watch him because he's
timeless and will last forever that's
how good a character he is this in no
way represents any of it it's the wrong
mood the wrong look the wrong feel and
the wrong humor I love this character
even to this day and usually when they
don't get him right I still love it
because he's so easy to love this is the
first time I actually felt betrayed it
trust me I've seen importantly
represented before but I still kind of
bought it because when that stuff failed
it still at least try to represent the
heart and spirit of love Garfield was
here you feel every lazy manipulative
empty corporate whoring second like
you're watching a funeral at a pet
cemetery I will still always love
Garfield but only when some element of
care even the tiniest bit is put in as
far as I'm concerned I don't see any of
that effort here therefore I don't see
Garfield
then I'm pretty good at spotting the
real thing
speaking of wedging action or done we
don't care it's a dog-eat-dog world boy
blood tasting time assholes
I am help us that
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe I'll get a cat scan a cat scan